Only a few months ago,
the term NFT was exploding
all over the internet.
Now to the latest trend,
the skyrocketing prices for
digital arts sold as NFTs-
The Christie's auction for
digital artist, Beeple,
coming to a close a few moments ago,
the final bid, $69 million.
$69 million.
I think it probably means digital artists
here to stay.
Anybody in this sector has to admit
that they were shocked by the size
and the ferocity and
speed that the industry
evolved so quickly.
The number of wallets
that were purchasing NFTs
skyrocketed the number
of transactions of NFTs,
across the board skyrocketed.
And the prices for many
NFT artists also went up,
but that came down very, very fast.
Once red hot NFTs are
now cooling off a bit.
The secondary market for the majority
of Beeple's paintings today is down 90-95%
from the peak, as is most NFT art.
But even more recently,
NFTs had been on the rise once again.
And even with significant value volatility
in NFT artwork, NFT
collectibles like NBA top shot
and NFT-based video games
like "Axie infinity"
have surged in popularity.
The correction that kinda happened
with the NFT art side is healthy.
And what we're gonna
see come out of that now
are projects that actually have utility,
that will be able to affect a
much wider amount of people.
I think that's where the excitement is.
And many companies are betting
that NFTs will enter the
video game world in a big way,
which if successful, could open NFTs
to a massive new audience,
and forever change the way
we value digital objects.
We are in the process of an exodus
from the physical world
to these digital worlds
that have been created
over the last 20 years.
And that continue to be created
and where people are
spending an increasing amount
of their conscious time.
You may have heard by now that NFTs
stands for non-fungible token.
But explaining exactly what
that means can get complicated.
So for our purposes,
what you need to know is that
through blockchain technology,
digital objects, like a JPEG
file or a virtual sneaker,
or even a meme that you'd
normally think about
as being infinitely reproducible
can now be made scarce.
So for example, if you're resourceful,
the video you're watching right now
could be downloaded from YouTube,
and you could copy and paste
it as much as you'd like.
In theory, it is infinitely reproducible.
Tokenizing or minting is the
process you can go through
via blockchain, where you can
create a record of scarcity.
In the blockchain,
you can enter into a ledger
that there are only 1,000
versions of this video
or 100, or even just one.
Taking something that was
infinitely replicatable
and giving it artificial scarcity.
And if you're rushing out to try
and download this video now,
thinking you'll make a quick buck,
that's not exactly how it works.
Only the holder of the NFT
and what are known as digital wallets
can actually own the item.
And they can choose to resell them
in exchange for cryptocurrencies.
But while we have seen
some high sale prices,
are buying these NFTs
actually a good investment?
I would hesitate to call
NFTs an asset class,
they are an asset.
In the same way that I
would hesitate to call art
an asset class, art is an asset.
But for it to achieve an asset class,
it really needs to be something
that you can buy and
sell, and buy and sell.
This is Bloomberg's art
reporter, James Tarmy.
So all you have to do when you
think about the art market,
and you think about the
prices that are paid for these
$10 million paintings,
$20 million paintings,
$30 million paintings,
is thinking about what kind of liquidity
you need to have to spend $30 million
on something that you
cannot resell anytime soon.
Sold!
There is not a line of people
waiting to spend $30
million on the painting
that you just bought.
There might be one other person
or maybe two other people,
but that's no guarantee
that those two other people
wanna buy that painting when
you wanna sell that painting.
And this is similar in the NFT space.
The number of people able to spend
large sums of cryptocurrency on NFTs
is relatively small.
And a lot of people became very interested
in jumping on the bandwagon.
There was a world that was opened up
to a general public that
they didn't know about.
And that seems like a world
of infinite possibilities.
And so corporations suddenly
started releasing NFTs.
Charmin toilet paper released an NFT.
I just got an email about
Campbell's soups first NFT.
And this isn't just about artworks.
This is also about the various NFTs
that are connected to
games and virtual worlds,
and so forth.
People are connecting houses to NFTs,
they're connecting
physical artworks to NFTs,
they're connecting portions
of an entire soccer team
in a Mexican soccer league to NFTs.
And then something weird
started to happen, right?
More people were making
NFTs than buying NFTs.
So you had a lot of people
trying to jump on a bandwagon
that might not really have
existed in the first place.
And while the initial boom of interest
did drive more people to participate
in the NFT marketplace than before,
those numbers are still relatively small.
According to a 2021
report by nonfungible.com,
weekly active wallets,
in theory, the number of
people who bought and sold NFTs
in a given week peaked at only 40,000.
And if NFTs are going to
become the asset class
of the digital future,
the number of buyers and sellers
in the market must increase by a lot.
There's still a tremendous
amount of friction.
To get a Metamask wallet,
to understand the idea
of holding private keys,
to engage with this world,
it's a process.
This is Sam Englebardt.
He's the general partner
at a venture business
called Galaxy Interactive.
They currently manage a $500 million fund
investing in technology and content
aimed towards the future
of digital worlds.
I spend a lot of time these days,
first, trying to just define
what the metaverse is.
And then make sure we're all
talking about the same thing,
because I think we're
still quite a ways away
from an immersive world
like "Ready Player One,"
being something that we all inhabit.
Except for eating, sleeping,
and bathroom breaks,
whatever people wanna do,
they do it in the Oasis.
I think we are very, very close,
and witnessing every day though,
the exodus from a purely physical world
to an increasingly immersive
synthetic digital world
that doesn't look like
one place we all go to,
but it's actually just the amalgamation
of the different digital worlds
that we experience on our various devices.
And a lot of players
are investing in this
future digital world.
A recent Bloomberg intelligence report
believes that the market
opportunity for the metaverse
could be $800 billion by 2024.
And for Galaxy Interactive,
one of their biggest
investments has been in gaming.
I don't believe long-term
that just by making something an NFT,
it's gonna be interesting enough
to be all that meaningful unless you build
some sort of a game or metagame
into the process of collecting itself.
Merging NFTs with games
has already seen some great success.
One of the earliest breakout
NFTs was "CryptoKitties,"
cartoon cats that users can
buy, sell, and even breed.
The NFT became so popular at one point
that it clogged the entire
Ethereum network back in 2017.
And it continues to have
an active community today.
And one of the drivers of
increased digital wallets
post the NFT boom in early 2021
has been a game called "Axie Infinity."
These pokemon-like creatures
are all unique NFTs
that a user can buy into and level up
by playing in a new business model
known as play-to-earn.
What could be better than a free game?
Well, how about a game
that pays you to play it.
So far, it's allowed people
in developing economies like
the Philippines and Vietnam
to earn real money through playing.
And now a team of veteran
video game developers
at Mythical Games are working
on their first NFT based
game, "Blankos Block Party."
With real toys in real life,
the way to keep their value
is you put them in a box,
you put them on a shelf,
you leave them there,
but with "Blankos," as you play with them,
they get better.
Most games, if you bought
Spider-Man character
or you bought a "League of Legends" skin,
they're virtual items.
They stay within that ecosystem.
Once you buy them, you bought them, right?
There's nothing else you
could really do with them
at that point.
And what we're doing
in a kind of experimentation with Blankos
is players own them.
They can sell these assets,
they can level them up,
and mash them up to create
new ones and all that.
So it really gives the
players a lot of freedom
to build, play, and earn.
This is Mythical Games CEO, John Linden.
He sees games as a great
means to introduce more people
into the NFT and crypto world.
So one of the goals in
Mythical was we really wanted
to bring this concept of
blockchain and NFT assets
to the mainstream gamer, right?
So maybe someone that doesn't
fully understand crypto
and is not an investor in Ethereum,
we really wanted to make sure
that they could partake in this economy.
And his success in this space
isn't necessarily about
having big headline grabbing
single asset sales,
but rather having a much
larger volume of sales overall.
We're not thinking about
it in terms of a $10 item
is worth $1 million the next day.
We're thinking about
it terms of a $10 item
that becomes worth $25.
And a $25 item that becomes worth $40.
And a $40 item that becomes worth $75.
And those are still,
if you think about it, those are amazing.
They don't sound sexy, but they're amazing
returns on investments, right?
So we're definitely thinking about it
in terms of something that's attainable.
Something that the average consumer
can actually partake in.
Latest trades, $55, $20.
Not kind of a new fine art
to were only a very few select people
can actually see that appreciation
because the numbers are just so ridiculous
that you can't can't participate.
But growing the market for NFTs
currently can come at
some pretty large costs.
Each transaction requires a ton of energy
from computers all around the world,
potentially resulting in
increased carbon emissions.
And although the Ethereum
network is hard at work
to reduce this overall energy consumption,
it does remain to this day, too high
to support a scaled version of this model.
What we're starting to
see technologically now
is the need to advance the underlying tech
so that you can have a business
around the purchase, and
sale, and trading of objects
that are $1, $5, $20, $50.
That's partly why Mythical Games
is using their own blockchain technology
within their Mythical economic engine.
But it's also because they believe
that creating and selling
an NFT game engine
will help create more
NFT games in the future.
What we set out to do
at the very beginning
was to build this economic engine
to where we could ultimately have
a lot of the top games in the world
be able to access this type of technology,
have the regulatory side covered,
have access to marketplace tech.
Things that normal game studios
wouldn't be building themselves.
We think that this type of economy
will really permeate
through every game type.
And honestly, I can see
almost every game out there
could have some version of this.
But building the technology
is only the first step to building value.
Gaming also offers another important step
in this process, community.
Blockchain doesn't make a game better.
We kinda joke here that if your game sucks
without blockchain, it's gonna
suck with blockchain, right?
What makes this technology
powerful and interesting
is the ability to ignite a community.
And if you build the right community,
then the things you own,
digital objects in a lot of cases,
will be valuable within that community
and people are gonna wanna own them,
and they're gonna wanna trade
them amongst each other.
We seen an amazing community
formed around Blankos.
And even before the game came out,
we've had about $1 million of Blankos sold
because players saw that value,
and they collaborated with each other.
And were excited by the
outcome of where that can go.
For someone outside of
the Blankos community,
It might seem outrageous to spend $5,000
on a virtual doll.
Just like for many,
it's outrageous to spend $69 million
on this Beeple's piece.
Or for spending $120,000 on a
banana duct taped to a wall.
Value for things that have no use value
is entirely the result of perception.
A Picasso is just oil paint on canvas.
It's worth nothing, it does nothing.
It is valuable because we as a society
have decided that it's valuable.
Could NFTs become a brief,
weird piece of history?
Absolutely.
Could they become an integral part
of the way that we engage with each other
and companies online?
Absolutely.